[Music]
Sharna has said many times that you and
her are like long-lost brother and
sister that you guys are so close what
do you think of her in Bonners a
chemistry connection I mean you know
there's there's some there that's for
sure you got a very very good looking
kind of southern gentleman if he can
make her happy then James Hinchcliffe
should know the IndyCar driver room but
his way through season 23 of Dancing
with the Stars with his pro partner
Sharna Burgess so we just had to grill
James about his thoughts on Sharna and
her hot new partner Bonner Bolton do you
think that Bonner is interested in
Sharna based on what you've seen I would
say that there's sad there's some
interest there for sure do you think
that Sharn is interested in Bonner I
think we all saw in the package I think
in week two there was some some
hand-holding action going on there have
you ever tried to set her up with anyone
there was uh there was one friend of
mine who will remain nameless oh we
weren't able to get them in the same
room at the same time I haven't totally
given up on that one yet because there
might be something there if it ever does
happen but no I mean she she needs
somebody strong what do you think worked
for you guys in terms of navigating
being so close without it being weird
because you know you have your
girlfriend but you in China did have
such a great chemistry the big part of
it was was making sure that we included
Becky my girlfriend in as much of it as
possible you know we weren't trying to
hide anything there was nothing sneaky
going on and but then all three of us
could hang out three of us would go back
to Shauna's place and ordering ordering
food and watch a movie and we kind of we
kind of try to make it a big group thing
about it
you
[Music]
you